good morning Jack how are you good man
how you gone I'm doing okay if you
weren't a golfer what do you think you
would have become well hasn't got a been
involved in sports someplace I think
baseball was probably my best sport
growing up and but I quit it too early
and which was okay because the Gulf was
conflicting with it and you know I've
sort of tried all the other things and I
think my process of elimination
golf turned out to be the best thing for
me how important was your dad in
steering you to golf uh he didn't scare
me anyplace he just introduced me my dad
played professional football and he
played football basketball baseball at a
high estate and you know they did that
in those days and he was sort of he
liked golf and but golfers not in his
number one choice but that's okay once I
start playing it it became his number
one choice but to be competitive I guess
you can be competitive in football or
baseball basketball and be competitive
against your opponent with golf you're
sort of competitive with yourself and
the course would that be right yeah but
was that that ever something that was
you know maybe a little tougher to
master because you're not really
competing against somebody that you go
out and tackle or block well that's what
I actually I liked about it is that you
know other sports you really ended up
needing somebody of I suppose like
skills you might say to compete against
and golf you had the skills you competed
against for your own skills and how far
you could develop them and you could
develop them on your own time and you
could go out early in the morning and
come home late at night here you could
do it all day other sports you're only
limited to how much Todd practice time
or how much somebody else would do so I
suppose that's why I gravitated to golf
I was a I was a sports nut and I sort of
if I could be out all day and come home
and my mom grabbed me by the ear that's
what I did did you lift weights at all
no no I back when I was playing dating
the football players in the face back
then but I started I started working
with weights probably about not what I
felt forty I just liked things just to
try to
Cape Town but you also I can you be too
in shape to tone didn't go oh I don't
think it can't be too tone than anything
I think it's I think Golf is it Golf is
a game of long loose muscles if a game
you like to be as supple as you can and
I never believed in being you know
really tight strong muscles I thought
that limited your ability to you know
have a loose swing which I think you
need to have and so I was always very
careful of what I didn't and what I did
was wakes or anything else because it's
I felt like it's a it was I was I was
pretty strong and I used I used most of
my my exercise really revolved at
playing other sports while I was playing
golf I they I played in the basketball
league until I was 40 and I played I
played a lot of tennis I did a lot of
water ski and then snow ski and and you
know I did all kinds of things that
would would benefit different parts of
my body but never did anything that
would tighten me up he said Jack
Nicklaus the three-part documentary Jack
airs Sunday night following the master
how much fun was that
to sit down and do the interviews and
look back I enjoyed it is it here it was
just terrific he was is he did a great
job and he was funny and kept it light
and I don't know what I spent maybe I
don't know 810 hours I suppose doing
interviews and we had a lot of fun with
it and I think they had a lot of fun I
have not seen very much live scene just
a little trailer it was just a couple of
minutes of it and what I saw was very
good but I wanted to be sort of
surprised and see how it is so I started
waited until it actually comes on the
air but we talked about The Prodigy your
Prime and then your legacy the toughest
part of that to talk about was there
anything that was uncomfortable or
concerned you know I didn't really have
a problem of anything I mean we tried to
be very honest and when I grew up they
you know I had to deal with Arnie and
his army and you know Arnie was I never
had to fight him I just his army
sometimes but which is probably probably
the toughest thing I had in golf but you
know
that's part of life and it's it is what
it is our was obviously I was a big
Arnold Palmer fan too and so you know
that was it was okay with me but that's
heckling though to be mean you're trying
to compete with Arnie first of all and
the other golfers of your generation and
then you've got people who are yelling
at you or making trying to make fun of
you how difficult was all well I never I
heard that MacArthur and pay attention I
was too busy playing golf when it comes
to that first time you played practice
round with Tiger was at 96 at Augusta
when you played a practice round with
him probably somewhere around that time
do you remember it yeah it was not the
year yet he didn't win that year so I
think it had to be around there what do
you remember about that just a young kid
that had a lot of talent I first saw
Tiger hit a ball when he was 15 bel-air
and I thought he was I was very
impressed with it then and then I sort
of followed his his career as he grew
and then we played at Augusta and I said
Val you know this kid's gonna win a lot
of masters I mean I made a comment that
he could win as many as Arland and and
we combined but you know I was being a
little facetious by that but a dad but
at the time he was he was winning at a
great rate and he could have but
unfortunately for him he's physically
had has had his problem so Nike I feel
bad for him did you ever think that your
record was in jeopardy
why I wouldn't worry about my record if
your records are made to be broken if
somebody breaks him that's fine I want
to I want to just say if some guy they
played better than I did I want to be
there to shake his hand and say well
done and but you know Tiger obviously I
still think Tigers got the ability to do
so I just don't know whether physically
he's going to be able to come back and
do it I guess he's still earned I just I
haven't talked to him for a couple
months and I'll say I'm sure I'll seem
tonight at the master dinner we usually
sit next to each other and talk so I
assume we'll do that again tonight and
I'll find out a little bit more but
Tigers such a talented athlete he's he's
he's played the game beautifully he's
been as competitive in this talent as
anybody has ever played and to have all
the physical problems you have is
was a shame right now and I just hope
the overcomes them did you ever get
involved in something like Lexi Thompson
got involved in over the weekend that
was so strange you know I obviously
didn't see what happened when it
happened but I just saw the replay of it
that's actually what was she thinking I
mean it was it was kind of like you know
you absentmindedly put the coin down in
one side and put the ball back on the
other and I mean she would never miss
the putt in a hundred years so certainly
I don't think she was trying to get any
advantages away line up 12-inch blood
yeah and I just think it was it just it
was something that happens and I felt
bad for her she selects she's a nice gal
play golfer a couple times and I got
maybe just once and she could really
play and I just I'm sorry to see
something like it happened of course it
gets so much controversy and so much
play in the news it says it's just it's
not it's not record I if I thought she
did it intentionally then we talked
about something else but I don't think
she had ever happened but the fact that
the tour allows somebody to email in and
say go back and look at this from the
day before Jack that that's what to me
is still surprising well it was pretty
obvious and you know I said I think
that's a little so epic to me I've
always felt like once the scorecard is
signed the round is over move on yeah
yeah that and that's what I thought the
least be fair to her don't come out on
the 12 tee and say we're going to take
away four strokes here because in her
mind if you penalize her two shots
absolutely but she didn't sign an
incorrect scorecard at the time that she
was signing she did not write no she did
not
no she didn't sign anything that it was
that she felt was incorrect or her
people who accept her card fill was
incorrect so you know it's I think it's
a shame I think it's a probably the old
penalty would be disqualified yeah yeah
at least she could leash you she still
had an opportunity to win the golf
tournament and the other gal played the
last hole a little better than she did
but you know it's the way it goes and I
hope that you know you learn from your
mistakes I'm sure that Lexi's got a lot
of years to play golf and she's got a
lot more championships in front of her
and she'll
she'll just be a little bit more careful
next time and I'm and I know that as I
say I feel in my own heart that there is
nothing nothing that she did on purpose
it just happened what's the strangest
place you build a go of course or most
unique hmm I don't know I'm the most
unique place probably where I'm I'm just
finishing up a golf course and actually
I'm going there after I hit balls on
Thursday at noon I'm getting on an
airplane heading for Turkmenistan and
that's a pretty unusual place a golf
course is six miles from the Iranian
border and the city is white marble it's
it's a beautiful place of people are
very nice and the president there is
very very much a sports enthusiast he
wants to bring he wants to grow the game
of golf and he wants to grow a lot of
sports in his country so it's kind of an
unusual place because there's nobody
plays golf in the country now and we're
gonna end up doing several golf courses
there where's the strangest place that
you've been recognized recognized yeah
maybe there but but they know the Golden
Bear there ah no no not at all probably
but uh I don't know it's the strangest I
don't know that I'd be a hard question
answer I can I think that would be
somebody else would have to answer that
question well safe travels to Augusta
Congrats on all the success and
certainly the the charity work that you
and your wife provide and we look
forward to seeing you tee it up again
okay then I appreciated my shock all
right Jack Nicholas the three-part
documentary Jack airs Sunday night 9:00
Eastern and it's got three parts there
the prodigy the prime and also the
legacy it's three nights so it's Sunday
Monday and Tuesday the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience